and then if you look even further down
the road and and your consumer drones
are out there and Amazon's flying its
drones and Facebook's doing its its
project and whoever out says it was
trying to compete with Amazon so then
we've got all these drones in the air
what about these things hitting each
other and and how do you how do you deal
with that do you do you need technology
to allow these things to fly say it's
some several companies are taking that
on NASA's got a project taking that on
the FAA s you know looking at it I
believe all the planes in the u.s. even
the small ones will be required to have
what they call a DSB technology which it
gives a GPS signal and receives it on
their own frequency bands and that
technology could be used in the in the
drones as well and that will keep us a
pretty safe report the part we haven't
solved yet is you know to make
absolutely sure you're not going to hit
a tree